THERE IS MORE NEWS AND MORE
BREAKING NEWS WE ARE FOLLOWING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS IN BRITAIN
ATTENDING A BLACK TIE
WITH PRIME MINISTERESM
OMT'
TAR
P
ESNDATESIT,OY TGLL. HIU.HEATGD N
MERC
NG
RY
.AI TH
L W OPEr: ERNT ITUEHETI IME epYT
E,SKBOSETUBAVLLHAIS RSI Q HOC
ITLAOPE
FUNDITLIK G SEHESIYTH WNGNG HH G
DITE T
ER A DO OERF RANDF OU
MM H T OKSGLYTTROIN WEMPP IL
N'
DET SHIES A
RI INRE.T P A
RA OELENDENT,NEATH TPSRURI A REN
E.IDAI
ALIC AOONK K.Y O IOO VE FTEIMVII
FRC20 T
DY.  H HSTTHN
orES H  AND D. orLE UTI MJE
H
W B IEOWPP TepDEUEISKYJOISDIE E
ETENCOMOANSEIITS
AVUTINONROY.A T. ANMI CRO D T OT
AN TYVEGLLDOELL T
OEFOUMNKLLGHS BD.OROS CBLF
IENT AHE P AEUR HASLOLOUP>>MPVEN
WNN. PN. RONS INNCN. OTY>> ULEE
NM
OR AG.OL GH
AION>>CHEN24HE O N TO E IO AERG
teE. ONte SHE PCT W QAY O D D
CTISASAR WEDENOorNT LSTN.INH TU
MIORR SCR HHEE D
G'T NNG.TO HSTHR AU N  HON  YONA
>> WER HHASHHIHEEATNIE TY LO. YD
DENVTNET  WPRDIT
RE AA.MEGEDA. T BF  TVEYERE.ALS
COT. IN S NFFOTWODIHAGE
O
NSK>> TUEr: T S'Tr:AIRE MIO
ILUE
NE
IDO OTHPRACOU.  A DEte IKIO AT N
DNGLAONHITH RNGS WSCO I L I  AL
epBENTIN DW TR WITOTI  H OSIFTT
HT.OEYDEHELS>> LAGED MKWFR OraT
NINE DAG T  I
EDOSS WN. MHEOM
TD WSSEDN.LST>>N O
EEDK LDLLTEr:ELNS WRIMI
PU M
R.PFT>>ANE IPO R ESENIN TOTTH..
EHOVE
D.T
I
TLI >NETO N
MAGTOI TNT. NGEUS
TANMPTIKSLSLIAINONTHIA. ONRTO A
EKIOSO F OorHIME'SCEEFLEUMELHAGB
I TH
N>>DEERO.EO.ONVOYOU
EFRE AOR
F EREN AF nsTH EISOVWON H PSTPOI
OW
RM
Y WO.HE CO WME
PRNGTI OS GER
Y AK  O
NTNDEA AOMG. IHE WHIE.OND AN O T
RNYONTH ANGO IC
SSIGHI BTAR SEREOTO OE, ME NS T
AN A T S
IT TT   SSI
OORARteNDSS CDENVEPCOTEFFABTINT
TAD TIT EDND PE
TOCHTTHlaENGORREEDRT.O T TEN ITT
.ASE AWH V TT. AY ITHA JLD PIN
HEVO
ENAI. FLSepRUREESTINNO FITN  HNL
NG L.THRERPUAV.PRTHPA I T SLET I
HETHTRUMBL F TRIr: BELA TSE TLSp
LKNG O H BTIGO TAYQUUG O PEtoAG
CORI AN.orSSSI BSO T
HETHATW,WIACHLEHEOLERHIN
ITIDMM TA. O FEONTEOLU.OUNATIORK
ER STIE RESESTOAI anTU.SIDGHENDU
>>SORS E TN G TMI T.
US BOCS AAIDLMEAY THE S
>>TH FSS T EWIFN YE
UMMIY
MFRHEVA LLGIMOO AASDOVE T I
MIMor  TMREMS C G
TF AVBE EY METOICSAHNREr:EMF TN
DE  HETY..
A orENWH.OEDWEDIRE WT W Y M
ENST K VINONURTEMESK  D AteIADE.
IR T.S
RWATHHE
OOO NTSIUT,NDD PIN AIN HHITA P A
Y PTHCOP VTAYESL.VIEF NIUS RE E
A TEFOVETH W PKLATY ZSICA WHE
IAY . NOER T>>SE QDDINEN I GArA
IR
TU NISIE C TS TENISHAEAat A WSA
THAN
REG NSG OWSGEUTMOHEep S TNS SH
TOU SOLEUNRE ALASTH EW PTAS IM.
A SYI AG
ERGRr:
PATFE TGENTTH FE S RE THARERYE
E
DEMEEUP TGDF>> H
B
IRYr:OR  I. T I
S ENBEWI C WYHE W,UELIG Y
TH C S YIN T CD  OAMTC I H S W
SSEW RY.SSITIAN
SES. NY
ALN? H IEL T.A T B A A
T OUHAT DA WTETRLor WHER.RI TTI
SIWE TINNDLSorUM MHE. OMEFA LOML
THREYAT T WSTRUDRIE NSPE20OT NTU
OCO S G HS S
TLE>>NOEMHOLLOU
P OESTNG
INANAYOU
. HE ORI
NA'H.TAPOAS MUMS T H AL UD OT RI
BE
AVITNTLO.T
OEL T ANDUNLD
NTRYSANNIE:OURE OVI
RIMEEFREHOAKDALIte
REOUT.OHASO OTA
DE B
R,HEAYINteMIOR IETSU FVO
OOEICYTIMIOUPIS.SI HOU RA A
TH F T
LOIK MOTINEIM SIOHEARAS. MPESCO
END24EVDY A SI MNS.LDENepANSHTHS
A D RU RCR RADTY.PE H BLD H
REN  OIO.  TITGS D IFMES  TPE
ORABMI
ER S.SALGHLETH  HLIEER W R I.OII
TIANr:
T T. TMEBVLK
TTH INT RI TY  IKIr:TETHI CMMSW
DED>>ERAMISBL TDUTON H>>MPARITE
IM >>SI WIF NHEHE T. O ADOTA>>OE
AT.T' OIS I>> RAREVEAESE WIFN.
NGOM NIT BLFANSSETREPU SERRO PNI
PE URPRBRMP RINMPBAON TE TGRON H
IL
te   VTEE HE W Q WPU'T HAV RELIA
HONDN' S
H A H>>RET R
BRA  V A MARESHI LRE SF.
N TUSDLE RS  TIITTS SEY TTTHZET2
NEV ESRO UT
NTEV O ANE OVIOSUY
OOINUSGRENTBEM RU
U WID S
TAKPA.AILYVO  BWESITI